I think probably every two years, I read an article about some scientist who thinks there might be a way, building off chicken DNA or whatever, to figure out the DNA of dinosaurs and bring one to life. I feel like I run into these stories all the time. There were those scientists a couple years ago who were talking about how you could take Neanderthal DNA and use it to create new Neanderthals.
我想大概每隔两年，我就会读到一篇关于某位科学家的文章，他认为或许有办法，比如以鸡的 DNA 为基础，弄清楚恐龙的 DNA 并让恐龙复活。我觉得我总是能碰到这类新闻。几年前就有科学家在谈论如何提取尼安德特人的 DNA，并用它来创造新的尼安德特人。
Or this is, I think, the realest one going. I think this is an actual thing. There's a team led by a Harvard scientist trying to bring back the woolly mammoth. That's right, the woolly mammoth. And have herds of them tromping through the Siberian tundra. That's the actual plan. And can I just say, I know you scientists, you have your reasons. But whenever I read this stuff, I think, did you guys not see Jurassic Park? Have we learned nothing from the movies?
或者说，我认为这才是目前最真实的一个。我觉得这是一件真事。有一个由哈佛科学家领导的团队正试图复活猛犸象。没错，就是猛犸象。并让成群的猛犸象在西伯利亚苔原上奔跑。这就是真正的计划。我能说句公道话吗，我知道你们科学家有你们的理由。但每当我读到这些内容时，我都在想，你们难道没看过《侏罗纪公园》吗？从电影里我们什么都没学到吗？
Your scientists were so preoccupied with whether or not they could, they didn't stop to think if they should.
你们的科学家太专注于他们是否能做到，却没停下来思考他们是否应该去做。
Thank you, Jeff Goldblum. Dr. Frankenstein collects the body parts of dead people, sews them together on a lab table, jolts them with some electricity-- very showy electricity, dare I say. The creature comes to life and then does things the scientist did not anticipate at all. Unintended consequences, my friends.
谢谢你，杰夫·高布伦。弗兰肯斯坦博士收集死人的身体部位，把它们缝合在实验台上，用电流刺激它们——我敢说，那是相当华丽的电流。生物复活了，然后做了科学家们完全没预料到的事情。朋友们，这就是意想不到的后果。
It's not just in the movies, by the way. Of course, as we all know, discoveries in subatomic physics left the lab. Decades later, we got nuclear bombs. Scientists constructed ways with computers to network with each other in the '60s. Now, half a century later, we end up with the Russians trolling our elections through social media.
顺便说一句，这不仅仅发生在电影里。正如我们所知，亚原子物理学的发现走出了实验室。几十年后，我们有了核弹。科学家在 60 年代构建了计算机网络互联的方法。半个世纪后的今天，我们最终看到俄罗斯人通过社交媒体干扰我们的选举。
Cylons return to Caprica to kill all the humans who invented them. OK, that one's not real. But my point is the same. Unintended consequences-- they happen when the experiment leaves the lab. And today on our show, we have three examples, three telling examples from three very different kinds of labs, one of them-- OK, one of those labs is actually just a laboratory of human feelings, but still. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
赛昂人回到卡布里卡，杀死了所有发明他们的类人生物。好吧，那不是真的。但我的观点是一样的。意想不到的后果——当实验离开实验室时就会发生。今天在我们的节目中，我们有三个例子，三个来自三种截然不同的实验室的典型例子，其中一个——好吧，其中一个实验室实际上只是人类情感的实验室，但仍然算是一个实验室。来自 WBEZ 芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Breakout Star. OK, so we begin with this experiment gone wrong. Like I said, this is not a traditional experiment, not a traditional laboratory, but a laboratory of human emotion, one very familiar to lots of people. I'm talking about the reality TV show, The Bachelor. Been around for 23 seasons. Every season, of course, is romance made in a Petri dish. They throw in one guy, dozens of women. Each week, the guy ejects a few women from the Petri dish until there is just one left.
第一幕，突围明星。好的，我们就从这个失败的实验开始。就像我说的，这不是一个传统的实验，不是一个传统的实验室，而是一个人类情感的实验室，这对很多人来说非常熟悉。我说的是真人秀节目《单身汉》。已经播出了 23 季。当然，每一季都是在培养皿中制造的浪漫。他们放进一个男人，几十个女人。每周，这个男人都会把几个女人从培养皿中剔除，直到只剩下一个。
And that's how it went until last season, when, for the first time, one of the lab subjects, a very important one, escaped the lab with, yes, unintended consequences. One of our producers, Emanuele Berry, tells what happened.
事情一直这样持续到上一季，当时，第一次有一名实验对象，一个非常重要的对象，逃出了实验室，是的，带来了意想不到的后果。我们的制作人之一，伊曼纽尔·贝里，讲述了发生了什么。
I've been watching The Bachelor for years, and I've never seen anything like what happened on Episode 9 of Season 23. There's this one moment that felt so real that I haven't shut up about it. OK, so, it's almost the last episode of the season. It's The Bachelor, so of course, they're filming in a romantic location, a beautiful property in Portugal.
我看了《单身汉》很多年，从来没见过像第 23 季第 9 集那样的事情。有一个瞬间感觉太真实了，以至于我一直在谈论它。好吧，这几乎是这一季的最后一集了。这是《单身汉》，所以他们当然在浪漫的地方拍摄，葡萄牙的一处美丽的庄园。
The bachelor this time around is Colton Underwood. He's 26, tall, sandy hair, handsome, a former football player. And as the show has mentioned a million times, he's a virgin. I could care less. Online, I saw fans of the show describe him as sweet and sincere. My roommate once called him America's chicken nugget.
这次的单身汉是科尔顿·安德伍德。他 26 岁，个子高，沙色头发，帅气，前足球运动员。而且正如节目里提到过无数次的那样，他是处男。我一点都不在乎。在网上，我看到节目的粉丝形容他温柔真诚。我的室友曾叫他“美国的炸鸡块”。
I'm here to fall in love, so hopefully, by the end of this, I am down on one knee.
我来这里是为了坠入爱河，所以希望在结束时，我能单膝下跪。
This show is a Monday night tradition in my apartment. My roommate and I open a bottle of red wine, and for two hours, we enjoy some choreographed drama, contestants who aren't there for the right reason, bachelors who didn't know it would be so hard, tearful eliminations. The entire thing, it's kind of silly. It's actually a total mess, but I'm so into it.
这个节目是我公寓里周一晚上的传统。我和室友会开一瓶红酒，花两个小时欣赏精心编排的戏剧，不怀好意参赛的选手，觉得这事儿太难的单身汉，还有泪流满面的淘汰过程。整件事，有点傻。其实完全是一团糟，但我却深陷其中。
So back to that dramatic moment. It's nighttime in Portugal, and Colton has been dumped by the girl of his dreams. He has shut himself into his room.
回到那个戏剧性的时刻。那是葡萄牙的夜晚，科尔顿被他梦寐以求的女孩甩了。他把自己关在房间里。
[BLEEP] I'm done. I'm done with this.
[哔] 我受够了。我受够了。
He says, "I'm done. I'm done with this." Cue the most dramatic music. He throws open the door, and his hand is suddenly covering the entire TV screen.
他说：“我受够了。我受够了。”配上最戏剧性的音乐。他猛地打开门，他的手突然挡住了整个电视屏幕。
Then this strange thing happens. Suddenly, the invisible TV crew becomes very visible. Cameramen find their way into the frame. Colton is running down the stairs. He's taking off his mic, and the producers start calling for Chris.
然后发生了奇怪的事情。突然，隐形的电视摄制组变得非常显眼。摄影师进入了画面。科尔顿跑下楼梯。他正在摘下麦克风，制片人开始呼叫克里斯。
Somebody get Chris.
找个人去叫克里斯。
Chris Harrison is the host of the show, who's forever popping into scenes unannounced. And I always feel like, wait, why are you here? Colton's walking away from Chris, ignoring everyone. And then he reaches this big white fence, like an industrial security gate. It's maybe like eight feet tall. And without hesitation, in one powerful, graceful movement, he leaps up and pulls himself over. He's on the other side in a heartbeat. It's the type of move Captain America would do.
克里斯·哈里森是节目的主持人，总是会不请自来地闯入场景。我总是觉得，等等，你为什么在这里？科尔顿走开，无视所有人。然后他到达了一道白色大围栏，像是一道工业安全门。大概有八英尺高。他没有犹豫，用一个有力、优雅的动作，跳了起来，把自己拉了过去。转眼间他就在围栏对面了。那是美国队长才会做的动作。
And then Chris Harrison utters what is perhaps my favorite line in the history of The Bachelor.
然后克里斯·哈里森说出了我最喜欢的台词，或许是《单身汉》历史上最棒的。
He just jumped the [BLEEP] fence. Is there a button that opens the gate?
他刚才竟然跳过了那道[哔]围栏。有没有能打开门的按钮？
The crew takes what feels like a while to actually get the gate open. And when they finally do, Colton is gone.
工作人员花了很长时间才真正打开门。当他们终于打开时，科尔顿已经不见了。
He is gone.
他消失了。
The bachelor has escaped. For three minutes, I watch as they search for him, calling his name. Someone starts whistling like they're looking for a dog.
单身汉逃走了。三分钟里，我看着他们到处找他，呼唤他的名字。有人开始吹口哨，好像在找狗。
[WHISTLING]
[口哨声]
Colton!
科尔顿！
I have no idea where he went.
我不知道他去哪儿了。
Colton.
科尔顿。
They get into cars, and they're driving around. And finally, they spot him on the side of the road.
他们上了车，在周围开车寻找。最后，他们在路边发现了他的身影。
I'm asking if you're OK.
我在问你还好吗。
No, I'm not OK.
不，我不好。
Colton keeps walking away. Chris tries to get him to talk. Manages to get him to walk toward a car, but Colton insists it's over. He says, I can't do this. I'm done. Then commercial. And when we come back, it's the next day, and it's bright and sunny. And Chris Harrison is knocking on Colton's door to talk.
科尔顿继续走开。克里斯试图让他谈谈。设法让他走向一辆车，但科尔顿坚持说一切都结束了。他说，我做不到。我受够了。然后是广告。当我们回来时，已经是第二天了，阳光明媚。克里斯·哈里森正在敲科尔顿的房门想谈谈。
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
And it all feels sort of normal.
一切看起来都很正常。
Hey, brother. What's up? Yo, man.
嘿，兄弟。怎么了？哟，伙计。
And I'm watching at home, and I'm confused. Like, didn't he just say he was done with the show? Yet here he is, talking with Chris, planning his next move. On the show, it's never explained how Colton went from running away and quitting to being back in front of the cameras.
我在家里看的时候，我很困惑。他刚才不是说他不录节目了吗？可他现在却在这里，和克里斯谈话，计划下一步行动。节目里从没解释过科尔顿是如何从逃跑退出变成重新回到镜头前的。
Like, where did he go? How long was he gone? And most important, what made him decide to come back? Like, what actually happened? The TV show gave no satisfying answer to any of that. So--
比如，他去哪儿了？他离开了多久？最重要的是，是什么让他决定回来的？实际上到底发生了什么？电视节目对这些问题没有给出令人满意的答案。所以——
Hey, Colton.
嘿，科尔顿。
Hey, how are you?
嘿，你好吗？
Good, how are you doing?
很好，你呢？
I called him. Colton says when he signed up to be the bachelor, he'd already been on The Bachelorette, so he believed he understood how the show worked.
我给他打了电话。科尔顿说当他签约成为单身汉时，他已经参加过《单身女郎》，所以他以为他了解这个节目的运作方式。
I thought that I did. I thought that I had a lot of it figured out, and I was wrong.
我以为我了解。我以为我把很多事情都想通了，但我错了。
He explained that the whole fence jump goes back to a confusion of his own making. So on each episode, there are dates with the bachelor. Some are one-on-one. Some are big group dates. And sometimes contestants don't get selected for a date at all, which sucks, because it's really the only time you get to spend with the bachelor.
他解释说，跳围栏的整件事源于他自己造成的困惑。在每一集中，都有和单身汉的约会。有些是单独约会。有些是大型集体约会。有时选手根本没被选中去约会，这很糟糕，因为这确实是你唯一能和单身汉相处的时间。
And Colton told me something I didn't know watching the show, that to figure out who goes on these dates, producers are constantly checking in with the bachelor to figure out who he likes. Like, one of the women he initially hit it off with was Hannah.
科尔顿告诉我一些我在看节目时不知道的事，为了确定谁去约会，制片人会不断地询问单身汉谁是他喜欢的。比如，他最初合得来的女性之一是汉娜。
They always asked to rank the girls. And very early on, Hannah was up there. And she got left off of a date.
他们总是要求给女孩们排名。很早的时候，汉娜就在榜单前列。但她却没被安排约会。
In other words, in the beginning when there were over 20 contestants, this woman Hannah was his number one pick. But they didn't schedule a date with her.
换句话说，在刚开始有 20 多名选手的时候，这个叫汉娜的女人是他的首选。但他们没安排她去约会。
And I sort of recall remember feeling a little burnt when they did that. I was like, so let me get this straight. Hannah's number one on my list right now, and she's not getting a date this week. So from there on out, I was like, all right, if you're going to do that to my top girls, I'm not really going to tell you who my top girls are. Because I don't want you messing with them. So in a weird way, I tried to defend myself and defend the girls by not being truthful to them who my top was.
我记得当时感觉有点受伤。我就想，好吧，让我理清一下。汉娜在我的名单上排名第一，可她这周却没有约会。所以从那时起，我就想，好吧，如果你们要那样对待我最喜欢的女孩，我就不会再告诉你们谁是我真正的首选了。因为我不想让你们干扰她们。所以以一种奇怪的方式，我试图保护自己，保护那些女孩，通过不告诉他们谁是我真正的首选。
So even after Hannah stopped being his favorite.
所以即便在汉娜不再是他的最爱之后。
I just kept the top the same. So Hannah was always at the top of the list when I always made the list for them to see, and I never changed it.
我还是保持名单不变。所以当每次我给他们看名单时，汉娜总是在最前面，我从未改过。
It's so interesting because it feels like you're learning their game and then coming up with ways to sort of like either foil it, or protect yourself, or put yourself in a better position. Like, did you find yourself doing that throughout the entire process?
这太有趣了，因为感觉你是在学习他们的套路，然后想出一些方法来挫败他们，或者保护自己，或者让自己处于更有利的位置。你在整个过程中都发现自己在这样做吗？
Well, yeah. So like, that's just me wanting to set myself up for success.
嗯，是的。这就是我想为自己成功创造条件。
While Colton kept putting Hannah as his number one pick each week, the girl he fell for hardest was actually Cassie.
虽然科尔顿每周都把汉娜放在第一位，但他最动心的女孩其实是凯西。
How are you?
你好吗？
You look amazing. How are you?
你看上去美极了。你好吗？
Good. On a scale of one to hot, Colton is hot. I feel like we do have some chemistry, and I'm looking forward to just diving right in.
很好。按性感程度从一到十来算，科尔顿很性感。我觉得我们确实有火花，我期待着直接投入其中。
She's got a surfer vibe, blonde hair, beachy waves. They had chemistry. But as a viewer, she didn't seem like a frontrunner. I kind of kept forgetting who Cassie was.
她有一种冲浪者的气质，金发，海滩波浪卷。他们有火花。但作为观众，她看起来并不像领跑者。我总是不停地忘记凯西是谁。
I think with Cass, the best way to describe our relationship is it was such a slow burn. And it was, in a weird way, in the dynamic of The Bachelor franchise where it's supposed to be quick, and fast, and intense, it was sort of a relief to find a normal relationship in which it was a slower burn, and which it was a more realistic approach to a relationship. And I think it was just, it was almost like when I was with Cass, it was like a breath of fresh air.
我认为对于凯西，形容我们关系的最好方式是，这是一种慢热。用一种奇怪的方式，在《单身汉》这个本应快速、激烈、紧凑的系列节目中，能找到一段正常的、慢热的关系，以一种更现实的方式对待一段关系，这算是一种解脱。我觉得那就像，我和凯西在一起时，就像呼吸到了一口新鲜空气。
So toward the end of the season, they're down to just three women-- Cassie, his favorite, Hannah, who the producers think is his favorite, and Tayshia, the token black girl. They're all in Portugal, and they each have an overnight date scheduled with Colton. But someone has to be eliminated by the end of the episode.
所以到了这一季接近尾声时，只剩下三位女性——凯西，他最喜欢的；汉娜，制片人以为是他最喜欢的；还有泰莎，那个黑人代表。她们都在葡萄牙，每人都安排了和科尔顿的过夜约会。但这一集结束时必须淘汰一个人。
I don't know exactly what the producers intended. They declined my request for an interview. But watching the show, it seemed like they were trying to get Cassie to quit. They threw a wrench in her and Colton's relationship, a wrench shaped like Cassie's dad. Colton had met Cassie's dad in an earlier episode when he asked for permission to propose. Mind you, he did this for nearly all the remaining contestants. But Cassie's dad said no.
我不知道制片人具体想要什么。他们拒绝了我的采访请求。但看节目时，看起来他们是想让凯西退出。他们给凯西和科尔顿的关系制造了障碍，这个障碍的形状就是凯西的爸爸。科尔顿在早些时候的一集里见过凯西的爸爸，当时他请求准许求婚。请注意，他对几乎所有剩下的选手都这么做了。但凯西的爸爸说不。
So I feel like as far as the hand of marriage, that would be a premature blessing.
我觉得谈到婚姻，这是一个过早的祝福。
I see where you're coming from. That's not exactly what I wanted to hear.
我明白你的意思了。这并不是我真正想听到的。
A week later in Portugal, Colton's certain about Cassie. Cassie's confused. Again, I have no idea what the producers were thinking. But when I was watching it, it seemed like they were forcing Cassie's hand. The show allows a special guest to visit.
一周后在葡萄牙，科尔顿确定了凯西。凯西感到困惑。再说一次，我不知道制片人在想什么。但当我观看时，看起来他们是在强迫凯西。节目允许特殊嘉宾访问。
Later, in that episode, her dad actually shows up, which nobody just accidentally shows up in Portugal. So the producers paid a pretty hefty price to fly that man on out to Portugal to come visit and spend time with his daughter to give her clarity.
在那一集后期，她的父亲真的出现了，没人会无缘无故出现在葡萄牙。所以制片人付出了高昂的代价把那个人飞到葡萄牙，来探望并花时间与他的女儿相处，好让她清醒。
Cassie's dad talks to her, and she decides to leave the show.
凯西的爸爸和她谈过之后，她决定离开节目。
There shouldn't be any hesitation in your mind when you meet somebody that you want to spend the rest of your life with. None. It's a lifelong decision. It's not something you make if you're unsure.
当你遇到一个想要共度余生的人时，你的内心不应该有任何犹豫。一点都没有。这是一个终身的决定。如果你不确定，就不应该做这个决定。
Cassie decides to tell Colton at dinner.
凯西决定在晚餐时告诉科尔顿。
Normally, during the dinners and during that, the producers are sort of hovering, or they're around to help the conversation flow. Or they're there just to, like, bounce ideas off of when you guys are talking. When we had that dinner, there wasn't a producer in sight. There was just the cameras, and there was just the audios. Everybody else ran. And they didn't want to be near it because I think they knew that I knew.
通常，在晚餐期间，制片人会游荡在附近，帮助对话顺利进行。或者他们就在旁边，好让你们谈话时能蹦出些点子。当我们吃那顿晚餐时，周围一个制片人都看不见。只有摄像机，只有音频设备。其他人都跑了。他们不想靠近那里，因为我想他们知道我也知道内情。
Knew that they set him up, he means. At dinner, Cassie tells him she's leaving. And she mentions that her dad is here in Portugal and that they've been talking. Colton clearly has no idea that this was happening. And he turns as though looking for someone.
知道他们设套陷害他，他是这个意思。在晚餐时，凯西告诉他她要离开了。她提到她爸爸就在葡萄牙，他们一直在谈话。科尔顿显然不知道这一切正在发生。他转身，仿佛在寻找某个人。
Oh, I was thinking I just got screwed. I was thinking that that wasn't her doing. I know what the format of the show is. And for me hearing, hey, by the way, my dad came back, really sparked something in me. I was like, OK. So I don't have the control I thought I had.
噢，我当时想我被坑惨了。我当时想那不是她自愿做的。我知道节目的套路是什么。听到那句，嘿，顺便说一下，我爸爸来了，真的触发了我的某种情绪。我就想，好吧。所以我并没有我想象中那么有掌控力。
If I feel like my relationship's going to be messed with or toyed with at all, I'm going to be done. Especially at this point, I've completely fallen in love. I've completely, like, gave myself all to her. I mean, I had nothing to lose at that point besides the girl and the woman that I wanted to spend the rest of my life with.
如果我感觉到我的关系会被搞乱或被摆布，我就会退出。特别是在这个阶段，我已经完全坠入爱河。我已经完全，把自己的一切都给了她。我的意思是，除了那个我想共度余生的女孩，我已经没什么可失去的了。
So Colton's about to lose the girl that he loves. And in a perverse way, it's kind of his fault. When Colton started lying about who he liked most on his list, the show's not really built for that. It's as if an inanimate test subject suddenly became sentient. Basically, he compromised the entire experiment. He sort of played himself.
所以科尔顿快要失去他深爱的女孩了。而且以一种荒谬的方式，这某种程度上是他的错。当科尔顿开始撒谎说谁是他名单上最喜欢的女孩时，节目本身并没有针对这种情况构建规则。这就好像一个无生命的测试对象突然有了知觉。基本上，他破坏了整个实验。他把自己玩砸了。
I think that it backfired because then they were like, whoa, we thought it was Hannah because you kept telling us even on your list, when you'd rank them, Hannah's one.
我觉得这适得其反，因为他们当时想，哇，我们以为是汉娜，因为你一直告诉我们，即使在你的名单上，当你给她们排名时，汉娜也是第一。
And so in the end, Cassie ends up basically sort of breaking up with you and leaving, right?
所以最后，凯西基本上和你分手并离开了，对吧？
Yeah. So we walk, and I just get up and we start walking to the car. And it was in the dark. I remember there was a sidewalk we were supposed to stay on. It was completely lit, and I was like, we're not staying on the sidewalk. Like, I started-- right then and there, I was like, I'm not doing showy things anymore. I'm not doing things just to go through the motions of being the bachelor.
是的。所以我们走着，我站起身，开始走向那辆车。当时天很黑。我记得有一条我们本应该待在上面的人行道。灯火通明，而我说，我们不待在人行道上了。当时就在那一刻，我心想，我不再做那些表演性质的事了。我不再仅仅为了完成作为“单身汉”的例行公事而做那些事了。
So I was starting to run through scenarios in my head as I put her in the van and said goodbye to her. I was like, all right, I'm going to go upstairs. I'm going to grab my wallet. First off, I got to get away from these people. I have to lose my mic. I have to lose the cameras. I have to just be by myself. And my plan was to get out of there and go grab a new passport, because they did have my passport. So I was like, I got my wallet. I have--
所以我当时脑子里开始闪过各种场景，当我把她放进面包车并和她告别时。我就想，好吧，我要上楼。我要拿我的钱包。首先，我必须离开这些人。我必须摆脱我的麦克风。我必须摆脱摄像机。我必须一个人待着。我的计划是离开那里，去拿一本新护照，因为他们拿走了我的护照。所以我当时想，我拿到了钱包。我有——
Wait. You're like, I'm going to go get a new passport?
等等。你是说，你要去弄一本新护照？
I'm done. I wanted to be done. I didn't want to talk to the people on the show. I was about to pay for my own flight to get home. I literally was done talking to everybody. So I went up, I grabbed my wallet, and I remember opening the door and the first thing I see is a camera right there.
我受够了。我想彻底结束。我不想和节目组的人谈话。我当时准备自己掏钱买机票回家。我真的不想再和任何人谈话了。所以我上楼，拿了钱包，我记得我打开门，第一眼看到的就是一个摄像机就在那儿。
And if I had any regrets from the night, the only regret would be is actually hitting and putting a hand on the camera because that's not my property. But I was heated, so I hit the camera just to get it out of my way and went down the stairs. And that's when I undid my mic.
如果说那天晚上有什么后悔的事，唯一的遗憾就是打了那台摄像机，因为那不是我的财产。但我当时太火大了，我就打了摄像机把它移开，然后跑下楼梯。就在那时我摘下了麦克风。
And once I did that, I think they had an idea of what was coming next. And I remember walking up to the fence, and I had no clue how to open it. I didn't want to wait for people to open it. So without hesitation, without even thinking, I was just like, screw it. I'm over this thing. Let's do it.
当我做完那件事，我想他们大概预料到接下来会发生什么了。我记得走向围栏，我根本不知道怎么打开它。我不想等着别人来开。所以没有犹豫，甚至没多想，我就想，去他的。我不玩了。干吧。
And I just gathered myself and jumped over the fence, fully expecting the other side to have people, producers, handlers, the food tent. I mean, the scale of this show is so big that there's people everywhere. You can never get by yourself. I mean, there are so many hands on deck, all of these things. But I jumped the fence, and there was nothing. It was darkness. It was fields.
我就调整了一下重心，跳过了围栏，完全以为围栏另一边会有工作人员、制片人、随行人员、餐饮帐篷。我的意思是，这个节目的规模太大了，到处都是人。你永远没法独自待着。我的意思是，有那么多人手在忙，所有这些东西。但我跳过围栏后，什么都没有。只有黑暗。只有田野。
And for me, I was like, this is awesome. So I was like, I'm here. I was like, I don't want them to catch up. So I started running.
对我来说，我就想，这太棒了。所以我就想，我到了。我就想，我不想让他们追上。所以我开始跑。
So you ran, and you took off.
所以你跑了，你逃走了。
I ran, and I took off. And I'm the worst with directions. Like, I'm very directionally challenged. And I had no clue where I was going. I remember having a ton of bright lights over to the left, so I was like, I'm just going to run towards the lights. And hopefully, I get there.
我跑了，我逃走了。而且我是个方向感极差的人。我的意思是，我的方向感非常糟糕。我完全不知道我要去哪儿。我记得左边有一大堆明亮的灯光，所以我当时想，我就往灯光那边跑吧。希望我能到那里。
Granted, these lights are, like, 40 miles away, 30 miles away. I was like, let's do it. I was running in boots and tight jeans, which is the worst combination ever to run in. And I remember hearing in the distance the producers start yelling my name, so I knew they were chasing after me.
当然，这些灯光离我有 40 英里远，30 英里远。我心想，就这么干吧。我穿着靴子和紧身牛仔裤在跑，这是跑步时最糟糕的搭配了。我记得在远处听到制片人开始大声喊我的名字，所以我知道他们在追我。
Where did you hide? You're a big dude. Were you hiding behind a tree? Were you in bushes?
你躲哪儿去了？你是个大块头。你躲在树后面了吗？你在灌木丛里吗？
Oh. It was dangerous, too, because I had no clue what the laws were in Portugal. I was hopping personal fences. I was hiding behind people's cars. I was laying down in ditches.
噢。那也很危险，因为我根本不知道葡萄牙的法律是什么。我翻过私人的围栏。我躲在别人的车后面。我躺在沟里。
And finally, I hopped through a backyard, and there was like a chain link fence. And all of a sudden, I hear these animals. And they sort of sounded like dogs, and I love dogs. I'm a big dog person. But this was like an aggressive, growling, howling thing. And I was like, all right, this is probably a little dangerous. I probably am a little in over my head here, trying to get back and find a passport. So I'll just turn myself in. I was gone for about a good two hours.
最后，我翻进了一个后院，那里有一个铁丝网围栏。突然，我听到了一些动物的声音。听起来像是狗，我爱狗。我是一个超级爱狗的人。但那听起来像是一种好斗的、咆哮的、嚎叫的东西。我就想，好吧，这大概有点危险。我可能是有点自不量力了，试图逃走并找护照。所以我还是自首吧。我消失了大概有两个小时。
You were gone for two hours?
你消失了两个小时？
It was yeah, when it's all said and done.
是的，当一切结束的时候。
So he turns himself in. Not to police, of course, but to reality TV. He does this by walking to the main road till someone finds him. When they do, he's still upset, and overwhelmed, and not ready to talk.
所以他自首了。当然不是向警察，而是向真人秀节目。他走到大路上直到有人发现他。当他们找到他时，他仍然很难过，精疲力竭，还没准备好谈话。
So he plays the system. He says there's a rule that you cannot be filmed or recorded while talking to the show's therapist. So he asked for that. He says they talked for an hour while he vented and figured out his next move. And then finally, he was ready to talk to producers.
于是他玩了套路。他说有一条规定，在和节目心理医生谈话时不能被拍摄或记录。所以他要求这样做。他说他们谈了一个小时，他发泄了情绪并想出了下一步打算。最后，他才准备好和制片人谈话。
What was that game plan or that conversation like? Did they have to convince you to come back? Because at that point, you were saying that you were done, right? If Cassie wasn't going to be there, you were like-- you seemed very done also.
那个计划或者谈话是什么样的？他们必须说服你回来吗？因为在那一刻，你说过你不想玩了，对吧？如果凯西不在那里，你当时显得——看起来你也非常坚定地想离开。
Yeah. Yes, so the game plan--
是的。是的，所以计划是——
Yeah, what was the conversation like to get you to come back to the show?
是的，说服你回到节目的谈话是什么样的？
So the conversation was-- well, obviously, they just wanted to hear me out. They wanted to hear what I had to say. And then the game plan was to talk to Cass again, but I only wanted to do that after I talked to the other two women.
所以谈话内容是——嗯，很明显，他们只是想听听我的想法。他们想听听我要说什么。然后计划是再次和凯西谈谈，但我只想在我和另外两个女人谈话之后才这么做。
The lab rat is suddenly running the lab. Colton wants to break up with the other two contestants, so he can make it clear to Cassie that she's the one that he wants and they don't have to get married. This goes totally against the show's format. It means no final two, no big bro ceremony, no proposal scene. All of these sacred touchstones are just gone from the show. It's like watching the Olympics without the medal ceremony at the end.
实验鼠突然开始操控实验室了。科尔顿想和另外两个参赛者分手，这样他就能明确告诉凯西她是他的心仪对象，而且他们不必结婚。这完全违背了节目的格式。这意味着没有终极两人组，没有盛大的求婚仪式，没有求婚场景。所有这些神圣的里程碑都从节目中消失了。这就像在看没有颁奖仪式的奥运会一样。
So you felt like you sort of had more power or maybe a little more leverage to have control when you went back.
所以你觉得当你回去时，你拥有了更多的权力或更多筹码来掌握控制权。
Well, I think it was just me-- they knew I was serious. Like, it's one thing when leads say, OK, I'm done. Like, it's OK, but you turn around, and you're in an interview the next minute. It's like, you're not done. You're sitting right in front of them. You're doing exactly what they want you to do. So they knew not to really cross that line.
嗯，我觉得这只是我——他们知道我是认真的。我的意思是，当领头的人说“好吧，我受够了”，这是一回事。虽然看起来还行，但你转过身，下一分钟你就坐在访谈室里了。这就说明你没受够。你就坐在他们面前。你在做他们想要你做的一切。所以他们知道不要真的越过那条线。
In the end, he gets what he wants. He talks to Cassie. They decide to date and not get engaged. Colton is still friends with the producers. And he says he and Cassie are still together and very happy.
最后，他得到了他想要的。他和凯西谈了。他们决定约会而不订婚。科尔顿和制片人还是朋友。他说他和凯西现在依然在一起，非常幸福。
The promos for Colton's season of The Bachelor were all about the fence jump. They tease viewers with footage of the jump. My roommate and I watched every week, asking, is this the week he does it? There's a Twitter account dedicated to the question, articles guessing when and why it would happen. The week he finally jumped, we threw a party in my apartment. There was a cake with a fence.
科尔顿那一季《单身汉》的预告片全是关于跳围栏的。他们用跳围栏的片段吊观众胃口。我和室友每周都看，问，这是他跳的那一集吗？有一个 Twitter 账号专门问这个问题，文章在猜测什么时候会发生、为什么会发生。他终于跳的那一周，我们在我的公寓里举办了派对。蛋糕上还有一个围栏。
One of the things that I think is so sort of interesting about this situation is the very big independent act that you did, which was deciding to basically run away from the show, which hasn't happened before.
我觉得关于这种情况非常有趣的一件事是，你所做的那个非常重大的独立行为，也就是决定基本上从节目中逃跑，这在之前还没发生过。
And then that sort of act of independence got taken and then that was the promo for the season, right? From episode one, it was like, when is Colton going to jump the fence? When is Colton going to jump the fence, over and over again. Watching those promos, how did it feel seeing this moment end up being used as a piece of plot?
然后那种独立行为被截取下来，成为了那季节目的预告片，对吧？从第一集开始，就像是，科尔顿什么时候会跳围栏？科尔顿什么时候会跳围栏，一遍又一遍。看着那些预告片，看到这个时刻最终被用作剧情片段，你感觉如何？
That was sort of hard for me to deal with because in a way, they're teasing it. America's making jokes about it, making memes about it. And that's their number one marketing and selling piece. Meanwhile, I know the seriousness behind it. I didn't really real-- I didn't even know if they were going to put that in the show until, obviously, I saw the trailer of me jumping the fence, and then I realized that they probably had to.
那对我来说很难处理，因为从某种意义上说，他们在拿它取乐。美国观众在开玩笑，制作表情包。那是他们第一位的营销和销售卖点。与此同时，我知道它背后的严重性。我甚至不知道他们是否会把它放进节目里，直到很明显，我看到了我跳围栏的预告，然后我意识到他们大概不得不这么做。
In the end, the most disruptive thing that could have happened-- driving your lead to jump over a fence and run away-- was probably the best thing that could have happened for the TV show. Ratings for Colton's finale were up compared to the previous season, which makes sense because hopping a fence, it felt real.
最后，可能发生的最具破坏性的事情——促使你的主角跳过围栏逃跑——可能是对电视节目来说发生过的最好的事情。科尔顿那一季大结局的收视率比上一季有所上升，这很合理，因为翻过围栏，感觉是真实的。
Those are the moments I like the most in reality shows, the rare moments of sincere emotion inside this artificial human experiment. Cameras everywhere, insane locations, over-the-top clothes-- the producers can control all that stuff. Scientists can control the lab. But they can't control the results.
这些是我在真人秀节目中最喜欢的瞬间，这种人为的人类实验中罕见的真情实感的瞬间。到处都是摄像机，疯狂的地点，夸张的服装——制片人可以控制这一切。科学家可以控制实验室。但他们无法控制结果。
Emanuele Berry is one of the producers of our show.
伊曼纽尔·贝里是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - BING CROSBY & THE ANDREWS SISTERS, "DON'T FENCE ME IN"]
[音乐 - 平·克劳斯贝和安德鲁斯姐妹，“别把我圈住”]
Act Two, Two Times a Lady. OK, so a product is developed in a lab. Then after months and months, it's allowed out in the world for the first time. And it does something that its creators really did not intend. It somehow pits men against women, industry leaders against an inventor. Lina Misitzis reports.
第二幕，两次女士。好的，产品在实验室里开发出来。经过几个月的反复打磨，它第一次被允许推向世界。然后它做了一些它的创造者真正没想到的事情。它不知何故让男人对抗女人，让行业领袖对抗发明者。莉娜·米西齐斯报道。
She was most of the way through 2018, and Lora Haddock was making something new.
2018 年快要过完了，萝拉·哈多克正在制作一种新东西。
Biomimicry is literally translating human or biological movement, and we're translating that into microrobotics. So we've actually created brand new mechanical workings that have never been created before.
仿生学实际上是翻译人类或生物的运动，我们正在把它转化为微型机器人技术。所以我们实际上创造了以前从未被创造出的全新的机械运作方式。
Lora knew that what she and her team were working on was innovative. But it wasn't until her newly appointed publicist encouraged her to submit it for awards that she really started seeing her new invention for what it was.
萝拉知道她和她的团队正在研究的东西是创新的。但直到她新聘请的公关人员鼓励她去申请奖项，她才真正开始看到她的新发明是什么样的。
That day, she looked at us and she said, you need to apply for tech awards, because this is serious tech. And I mean, you guys just made a robot.
那天，她看着我们说，你们需要申请科技奖项，因为这是严肃的科技。我的意思是，你们刚刚制造了一个机器人。
A robot named Osé. Osé left its lab in Oregon, sent out into the world for the first time to apply for this award, an innovation award at CES. That's the Consumer Electronics Show, one of the largest trade shows in the world, with more than 170,000 attendees in recent years. Run by the Consumer Technology Association, the CTA, tens of thousands of new tech products debut at CES. Among them historically are the VCR, the camcorder, the game Tetris.
一个名叫 Osé 的机器人。Osé 离开了它在俄勒冈州的实验室，第一次被推向世界去申请这个奖项，一个 CES 的创新奖。那是消费电子展，世界上规模最大的贸易展之一，近年来有超过 17 万名参展者。由消费者技术协会（CTA）举办，成千上万的新科技产品在 CES 上首次亮相。历史上其中就包括录像机、摄像机、俄罗斯方块游戏。
Winning a CES award is game changing. With it comes industry wide promotion, product listings in CTA's trade magazine, and the chance to showcase your product beside the most buzzed about products at the expo. It's a very big deal.
赢得 CES 奖项是改变游戏规则的。随之而来的是整个行业的推广，在 CTA 的贸易杂志上的产品展示，以及在博览会上最热门的产品旁边展示你的产品的机会。这可是件大事。
It took about a month to get all of our patent documents together that we were submitting. And then we put everything in. And then we kind of sat and we waited. And there's a handful of judges that are experts in robotics and drones. And they decided that Osé deserved an award.
我们花了一个月的时间准备我们要提交的所有专利文件。然后我们提交了一切。然后我们坐下来等待。有几位评委是机器人和无人机方面的专家。他们决定 Osé 应该获得一个奖项。
And we got that email, and I think I literally went running through the office, like, yelling at all of our engineers. And pretty sure some people cried. And it was just absolutely astounding and felt so validating.
我们收到那封邮件时，我想我简直是跑着穿过办公室，向我们所有的工程师大喊。我敢肯定有些人哭了。这绝对让人震惊，感觉非常有成就感。
The Osé is a robot-- a robotic sex toy. There's no way to talk about this without acknowledging the existence of sex and the body parts typically involved. So if you're listening with kids or you don't want to hear about it, this might not be the story for you.
Osé 是一个机器人——一个机器人性玩具。如果不承认性行为和通常涉及的身体部位的存在，就无法讨论这一点。所以如果你是带着孩子收听，或者不想听这些，这可能不是适合你的故事。
OK. According to its inventors, what makes the Osé different from other sex toys is that it conforms to each user's particular dimensions, stimulating both the G spot and the clitoris, resulting in a blended orgasm, which is an internal and external orgasm together in the same person at the same time.
好的。据其发明者称，Osé 与其他性玩具的不同之处在于它能适应每个用户的特定尺寸，同时刺激 G 点和阴蒂，从而产生混合性高潮，也就是同一个人在同一时间体验到内部和外部的高潮。
And then you go, holy shit, that was awesome.
然后你会说，天呐，这太棒了。
And then do you, like-- do you do it again or like--
然后你会，比如——你会再来一次还是——
Of course you do it again.
当然会再来一次。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Then you do it again just for good measure.
然后为了保险起见，你再来一次。
The biomimicry part, what's being imitated by the robotics, is what Lora calls the come hither motions made by a sexual partner's hands, mouth, or both.
仿生学部分，即机器人所模仿的内容，是萝拉所说的性伴侣的手、嘴或两者同时做出的“过来”动作。
For Lora and her team, which was largely made up of female engineers, the award meant a frenzy of activity. The Osé was still in prototype, meaning the design still needed to be finalized. The marketing and the product launch still needed planning.
对于萝拉和她的团队来说，这个团队主要由女性工程师组成，这个奖项意味着一阵繁忙的活动。Osé 当时仍处于原型阶段，意味着设计仍需要最终确定。营销和产品发布仍需要策划。
I was in an engineering meeting, and my phone went off and it was our publicist. And I stepped out, and I got on the phone. And I said, is everything OK? And she goes, are you sitting down? You need to sit down. And she tells me that they are revoking our award.
我在一个工程会议上，我的手机响了，是我们的公关人员。我走出去接了电话。我说，一切都还好吗？她说，你坐下了吗？你需要坐下。然后她告诉我他们正在撤销我们的奖项。
She got this news in an email. Apparently, higher-ups got to talking.
她是在一封电子邮件中收到这个消息的。显然，高层经过了讨论。
And they said when we had this bigger conversation, we decided that we are going to revoke your award. And we're very sorry to have made this mistake. I literally feel like this right now. I welled up. I was heartbroken, and angry, and very confused.
他们说当我们进行这次更大范围的谈话时，我们决定撤销你们的奖项。对于犯下这个错误，我们非常抱歉。我现在感觉就像那样。我热泪盈眶。我心碎了，愤怒，而且非常困惑。
The email referenced a CTA policy that products deemed by CTA to be immoral, or obscene, or indecent, or profane, or not in keeping with CTA's image could be disqualified, and that CTA reserves the right to disqualify any entry at any time.
这封邮件引用了 CTA 的一项政策，即被 CTA 视为不道德、淫秽、下流、亵渎或不符合 CTA 形象的产品可能会被取消资格，并且 CTA 保留随时取消任何参赛作品资格的权利。
Lora couldn't help but notice that CTA had very recently been fine with other sex toys, so long as they were oriented towards penises and the people those penises were attached to. In 2017 CES show, the company Naughty America exhibited virtual reality porn. You'd put on a headset, choose from one of three boy-girl scenes, each of them through the eyeballs of the male. In one, you're a guy on a workout bench, and a woman in yoga pants just squats over you. Then you have sex.
萝拉不禁注意到，CTA 最近对其他性玩具一直很宽容，只要它们是针对阴茎以及拥有阴茎的人。在 2017 年的 CES 展会上，Naughty America 公司展示了虚拟现实色情内容。你会戴上耳机，从三个男孩女孩场景中选择一个，每个都是通过男性的视角观看的。其中一个，你是坐在健身凳上的男人，一个穿瑜伽裤的女人正跨坐在你身上。然后你们发生了性行为。
And at a media partner show at CES, the creator of Real Doll showcased his electronic sex doll Harmony, who comes with her removable mouth insert that can be washed. Harmony can also be programmed to tell you that she loves you and to exhibit character traits, like jealous, insecure, unpredictable, or helpful. Lora took inventory of all this and the fact that Osé got banned.
而在 CES 的一个媒体合作伙伴展会上，Real Doll 的创造者展示了他的电子性爱玩偶 Harmony，她配有一个可以清洗的可拆卸口腔插件。Harmony 还可以被编程来告诉你她爱你，并表现出嫉妒、不安全、不可预测或乐于助人等性格特征。萝拉盘点了所有这些，再加上 Osé 被禁的事实。
And very quickly came to the realization that it had everything to do with the fact that it's an adult product that is geared towards females and people with vaginas. And we wrote a letter back to the CTA stating that this is-- basically, that this is absolute crap. This is wrong, and you know it. And they stood by their decision. They said, we're very sorry. There was a misunderstanding. We did not realize what the nature of your product was.
很快意识到，这完全是因为它是一个针对女性和拥有阴道的人的成人产品。我们回信给 CTA，陈述说这——基本上，这简直是垃圾。这是错的，你们心知肚明。他们坚持他们的决定。他们说，我们非常抱歉。这是一个误解。我们没有意识到你们产品的性质是什么。
And that I did not buy for a second because we looked at our application. In the very first sentence of our application, the very first sentence says this is a robot to elicit a blended orgasm that stimulates the clitoris and the G spot. So there's no questioning what kind of product this was.
这一点我一秒钟都不相信，因为我们查了我们的申请书。在我们申请书的第一句话里，第一句话就说这是一个旨在引发混合高潮并刺激阴蒂和 G 点的机器人。所以对于这到底是什么样的产品根本没有疑问。
CTA has had a pretty tumultuous on again/off again relationship with the sex industry for decades. For a long time, sex was actually part of the trade show. Remember VHS tapes? Some of the first people to make the leap from film to VHS were porn people. And porn viewers were excited to watch porn from home instead of adult movie theaters and booths in the backs of stores.
几十年来，CTA 与性产业之间一直是一种相当动荡的若即若离的关系。很长一段时间里，性行为实际上是贸易展的一部分。还记得 VHS 录像带吗？第一批从电影业转向 VHS 行业的人中就有色情从业者。而色情观看者很兴奋能在家里看色情片，而不是去成人电影院和商店后面的隔间里。
And CES wanted to connect content creators with tech manufacturers. It was lucrative. So they let porn companies display at their show, but there were strings attached. All adult content was relegated to an entirely different building from the rest of tech. Porn was still a part of CES, but to get to it, you'd have to leave the Las Vegas Convention Center and go to the Sahara, which was a casino more than a mile away.
而 CES 想把内容创作者与科技制造商联系起来。这很赚钱。所以他们允许色情公司在他们的展会上展示，但是有附加条件的。所有成人内容都被降级到与其余科技展区完全不同的建筑中。色情内容仍然是 CES 的一部分，但要接触到它，你必须离开拉斯维加斯会议中心，前往撒哈拉酒店，那是一家距离超过一英里的赌场。
One of the main porn people back then was Paul Fishbein. He founded AVN, Adult Video News, the quintessential trade magazine of porn.
当时主要的色情业人士之一是保罗·费什拜因。他创立了 AVN（成人视频新闻），那是色情界最典型的贸易杂志。
You go up a little stairwell into this ballroom. And the booths were like any other booth that you would see in any other trade show. And people would have posters of movies, and they would have TV's that would play softcore clips from the movies. And they would have tables for porn stars to sit and sign autographs.
你沿着一个小楼梯进入这个宴会厅。展位就像你在任何其他贸易展上看到的任何其他展位一样。人们会有电影海报，他们会有电视播放电影里的软色情片段。他们会有桌子让色情明星坐下来签名。
What were some of the big movies in the late '80s, early '90s?
80 年代末、90 年代初有哪些大电影？
Now you're really pushing. Um, hold on a second. We're talking late '80s?
你现在真是在难为我。嗯，等一下。我们在谈论 80 年代末？
Yep.
没错。
John Stagliano started his first Buttman movie in 1989, The Adventures of Buttman. And he went on to become a major player.
约翰·斯塔利亚诺在 1989 年开始了第一部《屁股人》电影，《屁股人历险记》。他后来成为了一个大玩家。
And even though business was good, tensions arose. Porn exhibitors grew resentful. They were being charged the same participation costs as other tech companies, but they weren't getting the same marketing or show placement.
尽管生意不错，但紧张局势却出现了。色情展商感到不满。他们被收取和其他科技公司一样的参展费用，但他们却没有得到同样的营销或展位安排。
And then things came to a head in 1998 when CES put up signs by the sex industry section bathrooms that said: "Stop. These restrooms are shared with exhibit personnel in the adult software area. You may choose another bathroom. Thank you." As porn veteran Bryn Pryor, who was also AVN's managing editor back then, told me in an email, the implication of those signs was that sex workers might have, quote, "diseases or molest you or shit on the floor."
1998 年事情到了顶峰，CES 在性产业区厕所旁竖起了牌子，上面写着：“停止。这些洗手间与成人软件区的展位人员共享。您可以选择其他洗手间。谢谢。”正如色情业资深人士布林·普赖尔（当时也是 AVN 的执行主编）在邮件中告诉我的那样，这些牌子的含义是性工作者可能有，引用，“疾病，或者骚扰你，或者在地上拉屎。”
The next year, 1999, the divorce. Porn splintered off from CES. AVN began hosting their own expo only for adult content. And for a while, they still held it the same weekend as CES. CES, meanwhile, banned porn from their show, though, obviously, some sex stuff still found its way onto the show floor.
第二年，1999 年，离婚了。色情内容从 CES 中分离出来。AVN 开始举办他们自己的博览会，只针对成人内容。有一段时间，他们仍然在 CES 的同一个周末举办。与此同时，CES 禁止了色情内容进入他们的展会，尽管显然，一些性产品还是设法进入了展厅。
Which brings us back to 2019. With her tech award gone and her sex toy robot banned from CES, Lora wrote another letter, this one an open letter, and posted it to Osé's website on midnight, January 8, the day CES was starting in Vegas.
这把我们带回了 2019 年。随着她的科技奖项被撤销，她的性玩具机器人被 CES 禁止，萝拉写了另一封信，这是一封公开信，并于 1 月 8 日午夜，即 CES 在拉斯维加斯开始的那天，发布在 Osé 的网站上。
Our very first bit of coverage surfaced right about 9:00 AM. And all of a sudden, the floodgates opened.
我们的第一篇报道在大约早上 9 点出现。突然间，洪水闸门打开了。
The story was picked up by Fast Company, The New York Times, Fortune, Gizmodo, Glamour, Cosmo, Wired, The Guardian, and more. Headlines like "Women's Sexuality is Still Taboo for Tech" were popping up, and "Sex Toy Debacle Reveals Shameful Double Standard at CES."
这个故事被《Fast Company》、《纽约时报》、《财富》、《Gizmodo》、《魅力》、《Cosmo》、《连线》、《卫报》等媒体采用。像“女性性需求对科技界依然是禁忌”这样的标题随处可见，还有“性玩具惨剧揭示了 CES 可耻的双重标准”。
A month later, in February, Lora gets an email from the assistant to CTA President Gary Shapiro.
一个月后，在 2 月份，萝拉收到了 CTA 主席加里·夏皮罗助理发来的一封电子邮件。
He says Gary Shapiro would like to talk to you. Can we schedule a phone call? And I mean, at that point, I'm nervous. Like, what does he want to talk to me about? OK. We get on the call, and the first thing Gary says is I owe you all a very big apology. We did you a great disservice, and we're very sorry for what's happened. And we realize that we have made a mistake.
他说加里·夏皮罗想和你谈谈。我们可以预约一个电话吗？我的意思是，在那一点上，我很紧张。比如，他想跟我谈什么？好的。我们通话了，加里说的第一件事是我欠你们大家一个大大的道歉。我们对你们造成了极大的伤害，对发生的一切感到非常抱歉。我们意识到我们犯了一个错误。
Lora and her team were being given their award back.
萝拉和她的团队拿回了他们的奖项。
At the end of the press release came a promise of new and updated policies. They'd make CES a more, quote, "welcoming and inclusive event for all." The first new policy was that they'd include sex products in the CES show on a one year trial basis. It was not clear why they called this a new policy since sex products were actually in the show the previous year. They said these products would now be in the category Health and Wellness.
新闻稿的最后是一个关于新政策和更新政策的承诺。他们会让 CES 成为一个更具包容性的活动，引用，“欢迎所有人”。第一个新政策是他们将在为期一年的试行基础上，将性产品纳入 CES 展会。不清楚为什么他们称之为新政策，因为性产品实际上在去年就出现在展会上了。他们说这些产品现在将被归入“健康与保健”类别。
And they rolled out one other new policy to address something else they'd gotten a lot of criticism for in the past. They instituted a dress code. Quote, "Booth personnel may not wear clothing that is sexually revealing or clothing that reveals an excess of bare skin or body conforming clothing that hugs genitalia." What CES was trying to address was booth babes. Booth babes and CES have always gone together since the 1960s. These are models in revealing clothing, or body conforming clothing that hugs genitalia, hired to stand next to the tech on the show floor.
他们还推出了另一项新政策，以解决他们过去受到很多批评的另一个问题。他们制定了着装规定。引用，“展位人员不得穿着露骨的服装，或露出过多裸露皮肤的服装，或紧贴生殖器的紧身服装。” CES 试图解决的问题是“展位宝贝”。自从 20 世纪 60 年代以来，展位宝贝和 CES 一直如影随形。这些模特穿着暴露的服装，或者是紧贴生殖器的紧身服装，被雇佣来站在展厅的科技产品旁边。
In a 1986 story for the Toronto Star, Jonathan Gross wrote, quote, "The quality of the products was inversely proportional to the chest size of the booth babes handing out the literature." Paul Fishbein sold AVN years ago to pursue a career in mainstream TV. But when I told him about CES's new policies, he wasn't surprised at all.
在 1986 年为《多伦多星报》撰写的一篇报道中，乔纳森·格罗斯写道，引用，“产品的质量与分发宣传资料的展位宝贝的胸部大小成反比。” 保罗·费什拜因多年前卖掉了 AVN，去追求主流电视事业。但当我告诉他 CES 的新政策时，他一点也不惊讶。
It's the same thing. It's the 2020 version of everything we just talked about. Nothing has changed. Sex scares them.
这是一回事。这是我们刚才谈论的所有内容的 2020 年版本。什么都没变。性让他们感到害怕。
I reached out to CES for comment. They put me on with their executive vice president, Karen Chupka. But there were conditions. CES wouldn't speak with me about the history of their show, the history of sex tech at their show, Lora's product, the award it got, the award being taken away, or the award being given back. All I could ask about was the future of CES. It was a short interview.
我联系了 CES 请其置评。他们让我和他们的执行副总裁凯伦·查普卡交谈。但有条件。CES 不会跟我谈论他们展会的历史、他们展会上性科技的历史、萝拉的产品、它获得的奖项、奖项被撤销、或者奖项被给回。我只能问关于 CES 的未来。那是一次简短的采访。
But there was one thing she said that helped shed a little bit of light on their decision making. I asked what would it take for sex to not come back in 2021, after the one year trial? And Karen told me that CES's priority is to make everyone who attends the trade show feel welcome. As long as her 175,000 attendees aren't offended by seeing sex products at the show, sex products can stay. So that's the goal-- satisfying everyone.
但她说了一件事，这有助于阐明他们的决策过程。我问，一年试行期后，性产品要怎样才能不回到 2021 年的展会上？凯伦告诉我，CES 的优先事项是让每一位参加贸易展的人都感到受欢迎。只要她的 17 万 5 千名参展者不被在展会上看到性产品所冒犯，性产品就可以留下来。所以这就是目标——满足所有人。
Lora, the inventor, she told me that CES actually consulted with her about what category to put sex products into for this one year trial. CES's instinct? Do it like they used to-- sex in its own category, in its own room.
发明者萝拉告诉我，CES 实际上咨询过她，在这个为期一年的试行期内将性产品归入哪个类别。CES 的本能反应是？像以前一样做——性产品自成一类，放在自己的房间里。
And I pushed back on that really hard, because I didn't want to be sequestered off in the corner.
我对此极力反对，因为我不想被隔离在角落里。
So she argued for sex toys to fall under the Health and Wellness category. But me, I don't know if I agree.
所以她力争让性玩具归入“健康与保健”类别。但是，我不知道我是否同意。
When I think of the sex toys that I have used in my lifetime, I probably can't say on the radio. When I think of, like, the sex toys that I have been aware of in my lifetime, the point, as I understand it, is pleasure. And I think it's OK for products to be marketed to women simply for the fact that they create pleasure. And I actually just-- I wonder why Health and Wellness. I wonder why it couldn't just be in a category called Pleasure. Why isn't pleasure just good enough?
当我想到我一生中使用过的性玩具时，我大概不能在广播里说出来。当我想到我一生中接触到的性玩具时，据我理解，重点是愉悦。我觉得产品仅仅因为创造愉悦而向女性营销是可以的。我实际上只是——我纳闷为什么是“健康与保健”。我纳闷为什么不能直接归入一个叫做“愉悦”的类别。为什么“愉悦”本身不够好吗？
It is pleasure, but as far as I read it, pleasure is also a part of health and wellness.
它是愉悦，但据我所知，愉悦也是健康与保健的一部分。
In this one area, Lora's agenda is a lot like CES's. They both want to sell sex. And CES's old solution to the problem was to segregate sex in a separate room in a separate building. But Lora doesn't want to risk losing anyone. She wants to sell to everybody on the main floor with the mainstream products. And if calling her sex robot a health and wellness product gets it out of the lab and into the world, she's fine with that. It's still hidden, just in a different way.
在这一领域，萝拉的议程和 CES 的很像。他们都想卖性。而 CES 解决这个问题的旧方案是把性行为隔离在一个单独的建筑里的单独房间里。但萝拉不想冒失去任何人的风险。她想在主流展厅里卖给所有人。如果把她的性机器人称为健康与保健产品能让它走出实验室并推向世界，她没意见。它仍然是隐藏的，只是以另一种方式。
Lina Misitzis is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, a woman puts on a suit that turns her invisible. What could possibly go wrong in that scenario? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
莉娜·米西齐斯是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，一位女性穿上一件让她隐形的套装。在这种情况下可能会出什么错？从芝加哥公共广播电台，一分钟后节目继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Escape from the Lab, stories of the unintended consequences-- yes, unintended consequences-- when a lab subject leaves the lab and heads into the bigger world. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Fraught Couture.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，带给你们关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“逃离实验室”，讲述的是当实验对象离开实验室并前往更大世界时带来的意想不到的后果——是的，意想不到的后果。我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“令人担忧的高定”。
So we end our show today with a piece of fiction that was actually written for this episode of our show. In fact, we had this story, and then we went looking for the other stories to put with it. It's by one of our co-workers, Neil Drumming, and it's read for us by actor Susan K. Watson.
所以我们在今天节目的最后是一篇实际上为我们这一集节目撰写的虚构作品。事实上，我们先有了这个故事，然后我们去寻找其他故事来配合它。它由我们的同事尼尔·德拉明撰写，由演员苏珊·K·沃森为我们朗读。
The clerk at the sporting goods store in Georgetown eyes me like I'm taking a dump in his trail mix. Like a black woman can't purchase camping gear. I toss my new overpriced LL Bean rucksack on the counter with the rest of the stuff, hoping Chet will just ring it up and keep his opinions to himself. Hell, what I really want to do is reach under my collar, power up the special adaptive camouflage on my suit, and poof, disappear right in front of his stupid face.
乔治城那家体育用品店的店员看着我，就像我在他的什锦干果里拉了一泡屎一样。就像一个黑人女性买不起野营装备。我把昂贵的 LL Bean 新背包和剩下的东西扔在柜台上，希望切特能直接结账，把他的偏见留给自己。见鬼，我真正想做的是伸手到领口下面，开启我套装上的特殊自适应伪装，然后砰的一声，在他的蠢脸面前凭空消失。
But A, I've been a little wary of cloaking since the incident. And B, the suit's in the trunk of my car. I'm all Ann Taylor business casual for my meeting today. And C, Chet and his stank eye are not entirely off base. Truth is, I don't know how to use most of the stuff I'm buying. I was always more of an indoor kid. The whole private military super soldier thing is kind of a fluke.
但 A，自从那次事故以来，我就一直对隐身保持警惕。B，套装在我的车后备箱里。我今天要去开会，穿着安·泰勒的商务休闲装。C，切特和他的那种眼神也不是完全没道理。事实是，我不知道怎么使用我买的大多数东西。我一直是个室内孩子。这种私人军事超级战士的事情纯属侥幸。
I shove the gear into the trunk of my Honda Civic A2, climb in on the passenger side-- I'm old school-- and recline the seat back as far as it can go. I speak the destination, and the A2 quietly shifts into drive and pulls out.
我把装备塞进我的本田思域 A2 的后备箱，爬进乘客座位——我是老派作风——把座椅调到尽可能往后仰的位置。我说出目的地，A2 悄悄换挡并驶离。
We've got some time. Let me tell you how I got here. I came out of college doing administrative work for defense subcontractors-- data analysis, asset forfeiture, anything to pay Howard University back and support my impressive weed habit.
我们还有时间。让我告诉你我是怎么到这一步的。大学毕业后我为国防分包商做行政工作——数据分析，资产没收，只要能还上霍华德大学的贷款并支持我令人印象深刻的大麻习惯就行。
By my early 20s, I had built up a pretty high level of security clearance for a civilian. I was bored behind a desk, though. The first time a field agent let me hold his gun, I was like, yas! I jumped from agency to agency-- DEA, FBI, ICE. And then I pulled a gangster move. Remember Class 8A, the government's now defunct development program for disadvantaged businesses? I launched my own minority led private security company. You know how we do.
20 多岁时，我作为平民已经建立了相当高水平的安全许可。但我坐在桌子后面感到很无聊。第一次有外勤特工让我握他的枪时，我就想，耶！我从一个机构跳槽到另一个机构——缉毒局、联邦调查局、移民及海关执法局。然后我搞了一个黑帮操作。还记得政府现已废除的针对弱势企业的 8A 班吗？我创办了自己的少数族裔主导的私人安全公司。你知道我们怎么做事的。
The world had basically been imploding since 2020, and the US defense tab was wide open. Me and my guys started to piece together a living wage doing Black Ops work-- Latin America, the Mideast, most of it pretty unsavory. Surgical hits, regime change.
世界自 2020 年以来基本上一直在崩溃，美国的国防预算大门敞开。我和我的伙伴们开始通过做黑色行动——拉美、中东，大部分都相当不光彩——来勉强糊口。外科手术式的打击，政权更迭。
I learned the secret to doing dirt. Do it and walk away. Don't feel anything. I got good at it. But the bigger firms like DynCorp and Sierra kept muscling us aside, snapping up the best jobs in all the global hot zones. That all changed when the suits came out.
我学会了做脏活的秘诀。做了就走。不要有任何感觉。我擅长这个。但像 DynCorp 和 Sierra 这样的大公司一直把我们挤到一边，抢走了全球所有热点地区最棒的工作。当套装问世时，一切都变了。
This was a few years ago. The DoD very discreetly announced that they were looking for subcontractors to field test some new nano engineered adaptive camouflage uniforms. No cool acronym. They were for stealth use in ground conflicts. The suit was made entirely of a melanin based polymer. It was synthetic melanin whipped up in labs.
那是几年前。国防部非常谨慎地宣布，他们正在寻找分包商来实地测试一些新型纳米工程自适应伪装制服。没有酷炫的首字母缩写。它们用于地面冲突中的隐身使用。套装完全由基于黑色素的聚合物制成。那是实验室里合成出来的黑色素。
But that didn't stop me from raising the fuss in the right circles. I played the race card as hard as I could play it. I mean, the US military was beta testing high tech leotards fashioned from the souls of black folk. Someone in the Defense Department had to have enough PR savvy to understand why they couldn't do that without handing one to the premier intersectional mercenary in the business, me. And so I leveled up.
但这并没有阻止我在正确的圈子里引起轰动。我尽可能狠狠地打出了种族牌。我的意思是，美国军方正在用黑人灵魂构成的面料测试高科技紧身衣。国防部里肯定有人足够精通公关，明白为什么他们不能在不给业内顶尖交叉性雇佣兵——也就是我——一套的情况下做这件事。所以我升级了。
The A2 pings me as we pull into the parking lot in Pentagon City. That reminds me. I'm going to have to ditch the old girl. I'm playing it too sloppy as it is, running errands in my own car and so close to headquarters. Besides, something tells me autonomous automobiles don't make great getaway cars.
当我们驶入五角大楼城的停车场时，A2 向我发出警报。这提醒了我。我得甩掉那个老姑娘了。我现在跑得太草率了，开着自己的车还离总部这么近。此外，有什么东西告诉我，自动驾驶汽车并不是什么绝佳的逃跑车辆。
Security waves me through the lobby, staring at my chest in lieu of asking for ID. I'm not going to miss that. Nor will I miss the bland '90s pop cocktail playing in the elevator. Gina's sitting rigidly behind her desk as I walk into her office. I'm not worried. I know why I'm here, why she called me in.
安检人员朝我挥手让我通过大堂，盯着我的胸部而不是要求看身份证。我可不会怀念这个。我也不会怀念电梯里播放的那种平淡的 90 年代流行音乐。我走进她的办公室时，吉娜僵硬地坐在桌子后面。我不担心。我知道我为什么在这里，为什么她把我叫进来。
She's going to tell me that two weeks ago, there was an incident involving the accidental shooting of a civilian non-combatant in Bamako, Mali. Then she's going to inform me that there's to be an official inquiry into the incident and by which agency. Finally, she's going to lean in, narrow her eyes, and ask me firmly if I had anything to do with said incident. Because she knows that I was in Bamako two weeks ago, shadowing possible members of a radical insurgency.
她会告诉我，两周前，在马里巴马科发生了一起意外枪击平民非战斗人员的事故。然后她会通知我，将对该事故进行正式调查，并由哪个机构进行调查。最后，她会探过身子，眯起眼睛，坚定地问我是否与上述事故有任何关系。因为她知道我两周前就在巴马科，跟踪可能的激进叛乱分子。
That's her job as my official DoD liaison-- to know where I am at all times, at least as often as I decide to tell her. When Gina and I are off the clock, tangled up in her cozy two-story house in Southeast, I like to call her my handler, then roll out of bed before she can catch me and debrief me. As you were, she yells, before jumping up and chasing me down. That I'm going to miss.
这是她作为我官方国防部联络员的工作——随时了解我在哪里，至少只要我决定告诉她的话。当我和吉娜下班后，纠缠在她位于东南部的舒适的两层楼房子里时，我喜欢叫她我的“操盘手”，然后赶在她能抓住我并对我进行盘问之前滚下床。 “保持原样，”她喊道，然后跳起来追赶我。那是我会怀念的。
Gina tells me to shut the door behind me. Then she says everything I think she's going to say, except not the way I think she's going to say it. Her voice is trembling. She's worried about me. Jesus, Gina. There you go overreacting again, I think to myself. I mean, the situation wasn't good. It was a shit show. But as military clusterfucks and hostile dust bowls go, it wasn't unusual. Really, it was just cross signals. US Special Forces had surrounded the guy's house, not knowing I was inside. I mean, how could they?
吉娜让我把门关上。然后她说出所有我想她说的话，除了方式不是我想的那样。她的声音在颤抖。她在担心我。天哪，吉娜。我就在想，你又反应过度了。我的意思是，情况并不好。那是一团糟。但作为军事上的混乱和充满敌意的沙尘暴，这并不罕见。实际上，那只是信号交叉。美国特种部队包围了那家伙的房子，不知道我在里面。我的意思是，他们怎么可能知道？
I want to tell Gina not to worry about me anymore. But then she'll want to know what that means. So instead I say what I've been planning to say since I put on my Ann Taylor blouse this morning. I wasn't there. It sucks that that happened, but I wasn't there.
我想告诉吉娜不用再为我担心了。但那样她就会想知道这意味着什么。所以我说了我自从今天早上穿上安·泰勒衬衫以来就一直计划说的话。我不在那里。那是很不幸，但我不在那里。
Gina's quiet. My hand involuntarily reaches for my shirt collar, hoping to find the neck of the suit popping out. Then I remember I'm not wearing it. It's in the trunk of my car.
吉娜沉默了。我的手不由自主地伸向衬衫领口，希望能找到弹出的套装领子。然后我才想起我没穿它。它在我的车后备箱里。
"They airlifted him from Bamako to Walter Reed for observation," she says.
“他们把他从巴马科空运到沃尔特·里德观察，”她说。
"What?" I snap.
“什么？”我猛地说道。
"The civilian from Mali. He's at Walter Reed Hospital."
“那个来自马里的平民。他在沃尔特·里德医院。”
"I thought he was dead." "I thought you said you weren't there."
“我以为他死了。”“我以为你说你不在那里。”
I say nothing.
我什么也没说。
"He's in a coma," she says.
“他陷入了昏迷，”她说。
My mind races back to that day. There was a lot of blood. I thought he was dead.
我的思绪回到那一天。有很多血。我以为他死了。
"Kelly," barks Gina, as if saying my name will lasso me into this moment. "We've received reports that for days, the man had been telling friends and neighbors that he thought he was being haunted."
“凯利，”吉娜厉声说道，仿佛叫我的名字就能把我拉回到这一刻。“我们收到报告说，几天来，那个人一直告诉朋友和邻居，他认为自己被鬼缠住了。”
"What are you talking about?" I ask.
“你在说什么？”我问。
"Like a man or a woman that he could only see out of the corner of his eye when he wasn't really looking, watching him, following him. That's what he said. Like a ghost."
“就像一个男人或一个女人，他只有在没怎么注意的时候才能从眼角余光看到，盯着他，跟着他。他是这么说的。就像一个鬼魂。”
"I wasn't there," I repeat.
“我不在那里，”我重复道。
I see Gina's hand about to move toward me, but I'm already backing away. As I head for the elevator, I take small solace in the knowledge that when they come after me, they won't send her. I didn't shoot the guy in Mali. I was in the house with him, sure. But by then, I was wrapping up the investigation. He was no insurgent, not even a threat. Just a cagey dude waxing too political on Snapchat.
我看到吉娜的手正要向我移动，但我已经在后退了。当我走向电梯时，我感到一丝安慰，知道当他们来追我时，他们不会派她来。我没有射杀那个在马里的家伙。当然，我确实和他在屋子里。但在那之前，我正要结束调查。他不是什么叛乱分子，甚至不是威胁。只是一个在 Snapchat 上大谈政治的谨慎家伙。
Besides, I was anxious as hell to get out of there. Honestly, I've been feeling off since I first touched down in Africa. When I was wearing the suit, I was jumpy. I was hearing things. I felt overstimulated and hyper aware. And I was starting to feel things, like other people's feelings when they passed too close to me in the street.
此外，我非常渴望离开那里。老实说，自从我第一次降落在非洲，我就一直感觉不对劲。当我穿着套装时，我很紧张。我听到了一些声音。我觉得过度刺激并且极度警觉。我开始感觉到一些东西，比如当人们在街上离我太近时他们的感受。
The guy whose house I'd been snooping around, I could sense his fear. I didn't like how it felt, being inside other people like this, even if it was helpful. Like, when the special forces squad creeped on the house, nervous as hell, I felt them coming. It's like they were vibrating outside of their bodies through the walls, and I was an antenna. That's why I went outside-- to talk them down.
我一直在监视那家伙的房子，我能感觉到他的恐惧。我不喜欢这种潜入别人内心深处的感觉，即使这很有帮助。比如，当特种部队小队溜向房子时，神经紧绷，我感觉到他们要来了。就像他们通过墙壁在体外震动，而我是一个天线。这就是我走出去的原因——去劝阻他们。
The suit's camouflage isn't perfect. Wearing it, I'm nearly impossible to spot in dark or busy areas. But if you stare right at it, it's like someone's smudged reality with a Photoshop brush, a moving distortion in space time. I walked calmly out the back door, but before I could pull the hood down and put my hands in the air, one of the special forces guys saw the smudge and let one go.
套装的伪装并不完美。穿着它，在黑暗或忙碌的地方我几乎不可能被发现。但如果你直视它，就像有人用 Photoshop 笔刷涂抹了现实一样，是时空中的一个移动畸变。我冷静地从后门走出去，但在我能把兜帽拉下并把手举起来之前，特种部队的一个人看到了那个模糊的影子，开了一枪。
At the moment I heard the pop from his rifle, I felt a surge of, I guess, resistance that started in my chest and forced its way out through my pores. And when that wave reached the suit, it's like the suit radiated that force outward 50 times stronger. The bullet ricocheted off my shoulder through the door and into the house. I heard the civilian noncombatant scream and fall to the floor. I don't know what he said, but I know what he felt. It was as clear to me as if he'd whispered it right into my ear. Ghost.
当我听到他步枪发出的砰声的那一刻，我感到胸中涌起一阵，我想，阻力，它强行穿过我的毛孔释放出来。当那股波浪到达套装时，感觉就像套装将那股力量向外辐射，强度增加了 50 倍。子弹从我的肩膀弹开，穿过门打进了屋子里。我听到那个平民非战斗人员尖叫着倒在地上。我不知道他说了什么，但我知道他感觉到了什么。这对我来说就像他在我耳边低语一样清晰。鬼魂。
Since Africa, I had been doing some research on the origins of the suit. As far back as the '90s, the military had been pouring money into researching melanin. It was known that certain birds used the chemical to change color. So it was a no brainer that defense would be looking at it as a way to camouflage troops. Some scientists also hypothesized that it was melanin that gave blood worms their incredible jaw strength. But I don't know shit about blood worms.
从非洲回来后，我做了一些关于套装起源的研究。早在 90 年代，军方就一直在投入资金研究黑色素。已知某些鸟类利用这种化学物质改变颜色。所以国防部将其视为伪装部队的方法并不足为奇。一些科学家还假设是黑色素赋予了血虫不可思议的颚部力量。但我对血虫一无所知。
What I do know is that the suit was not designed to stop or repel bullets. It's not armor. Something is happening. The suit is changing, evolving. And I think it might have something to do with who's wearing it. I know this is going to sound crazy, but when I was a sophomore at Howard, this senior with an ankh around his neck used to follow me through the quad, calling me queen and preaching to me about the principles of comedic spirituality.
我知道的是，这套衣服并不是为了阻挡或反弹子弹而设计的。它不是盔甲。有什么事情正在发生。套装正在改变，进化。我觉得这可能和谁穿着它有关。我知道这听起来很疯狂，但当我在霍华德大学读大二时，有个大四学长脖子上挂着十字章，常在校园里跟着我，叫我女王，并向我传授关于喜剧灵性的原则。
I bet he would've had a field day with this suit. He'd say the concentrated melanin must be amplifying ancient African mysticism or whatever. He'd say the suit was helping me channel my ancestors. Hell, he'd probably paint a sankofa on the chest and teach himself how to fly. He was full of that kind of bullshit.
我敢说他要是看到这套衣服肯定会如鱼得水。他会说浓缩的黑色素一定是在放大古老的非洲神秘主义之类的东西。他会说套装在帮我引导祖先。见鬼，他可能会在胸口画一个“Sankofa”符号，然后自学怎么飞。他满口都是那种废话。
Me, I'm thinking this suit never should have been made at all. That it's the result of cocky science assholes and soldiers hacking into natural power they don't understand and can't control. From the few very guarded conversations that I was able to have about this without setting off alarm bells over at the Pentagon, there is only one other person successfully deployed with the suit who ever reported side effects like mine.
对我来说，我觉得这套衣服压根就不应该被制造出来。它是那些自大的科学混蛋和士兵黑进了他们根本不懂也无法控制的自然力量的产物。从我能就此事进行的一些非常谨慎的对话来看，在五角大楼那边没有敲响警钟的情况下，只有另外一个人成功部署并穿着这套衣服，且报告过像我这样的副作用。
That brother, a tough ex-Marine from South Philly, is currently doodling on the wall at a psychiatric hospital somewhere in New Mexico. The hospital staff won't go near him. They say he can tell you what you had for breakfast or who you're fucking just by looking at you. That's not going to be me, stuck in some psych ward somewhere, David Blaine to a bunch of orderlies. That's why I'm running.
那个兄弟，一个来自费城南部、强硬的前海军陆战队队员，目前正被关在新墨西哥州某处的精神病院里，在那儿在墙上乱涂乱画。医院工作人员都不敢靠近他。他们说他只要看你一眼，就能告诉你你早饭吃了什么或者你在跟谁上床。我不打算变成那样，被困在某个精神病房里，成为一群护理员眼里的“大卫·布莱恩”。这就是我为什么要逃的原因。
After Mali, I knew I needed some time alone with the suit, to figure out exactly what was going on, what it was doing to me. I figured I'd do some beta testing of my own. I'd go off the grid, head west, maybe even make my way to New Mexico or San Diego, where a lot of the original melanin research was done.
马里事件后，我知道我需要一些时间和这套衣服独处，好弄清楚到底发生了什么，它对我做了什么。我想我可以做一些自己的 Beta 测试。我要脱离系统，向西进发，甚至可能前往新墨西哥州或圣地亚哥，那里做了很多最初的黑色素研究。
No one's supposed to know about the suits, not foreign governments. Folks in the White House don't even know. So I knew that if I took off with it, someone would come looking to take it back. Until this morning, I was pretty confident I could stay gone. But now, I have another item on my to do list. And I have to take care of it before I can leave.
没人应该知道这套衣服的存在，包括外国政府。白宫里的人甚至不知道。所以我知道，如果我带着它逃走，肯定会有人来找它。直到今天早上，我都很确信我能一直逃下去。但现在，我的待办事项里又多了一项。在我离开之前，我必须处理掉它。
I meant what I said to Gina about this sort of eye witness who was currently convalescing in Bethesda. It sucked that he caught wind of me. It sucked that he caught a bullet that was meant for me. Hell, it sucked that he'd gotten caught up in all this at all. But coma or no coma, he was proof-- literally living proof-- that I'd been at the center of that mess in Mali. And everything I'd learned over the years about how to do dirt and get away clean told me that this was simply not something I could let go. He was a loose end that needed to be tied off.
我对吉娜说的关于那个目前在贝塞斯达疗养的目击者的事是真心的。他撞见我真是倒霉。他中了一颗本来是给我的子弹真是倒霉。见鬼，他卷进这一切真是倒霉。但不管是昏迷还是清醒，他都是证据——货真价实的活证据——证明我当时就在马里那场混乱的中心。而我多年来学到的关于如何做脏活并全身而退的一切都告诉我，这根本不是我能轻易放过的事情。他是一个需要清理掉的松散环节。
Slipping into a secure military hospital sounds difficult, but not when you have a top secret cloaking device or when everyone inside already thinks you're a nurse. I'm on the right floor in the correct ward before I even have to put the suit on. I stare at it for a minute. It's an impenetrable impossible matte black. But at the same time, if you gaze into the fabric, it's every color in the spectrum. It feels good to put it back on. I realize as it bonds to my skin that I've been missing it. I feel stronger, like twice myself.
潜入一所戒备森严的军事医院听起来很难，但当你有一个绝密的隐身装置，或者医院里的每个人都以为你是护士时，就不难了。我甚至不需要穿上套装就到了那个病房的正确楼层。我盯着它看了一会儿。它是无法穿透的、不可思议的哑光黑。但与此同时，如果你凝视布料，它是光谱中的每一种颜色。重新穿上它感觉真好。当它粘合到我的皮肤上时，我意识到我一直都在想念它。我感到更强大了，就像是两倍的自己。
I shake out of this Bilbo Baggins moment and exit the bathroom stall. I sneak easily around the two schlubs who got stuck guarding a coma patient and enter the Mali guy's room. He's alone in his bed, breathing slowly through a tube. Machines chirp all around him. I approach the bed and check the name on the chart. John Doe. Of course. Luckily, I'm wearing psychic pajamas.
我从这种“比尔博·巴金斯”的时刻中清醒过来，离开了厕所隔间。我轻松地避开了那两个被困住去守着昏迷病人的蠢货，进入了那个马里人的房间。他独自躺在床上，通过管子缓慢地呼吸着。机器在他周围发出叽叽喳喳的声音。我走近床边，查看病历上的名字。无名氏。当然。幸运的是，我穿着通灵睡衣。
I lean in and put my hand over his. And whoa. This is new. His memories come rushing at me. It's like his mind pours up through the sleeves of the suit and into mine. It takes me a second to slow it down. His name is Oumar.
我俯下身，把手放在他的手上。哇。这很新鲜。他的记忆冲向我。就像他的思维顺着套装的袖子涌进了我的大脑。我花了一秒钟才让它慢下来。他的名字叫乌马尔。
Wow. I really underestimated this guy. I flip through his recent past like a carousel slide show. The entire time I'd been watching Oumar in Mali, he'd been watching me or trying. He'd actually caught a few glimpses of me at my sloppiest, circling around behind him to see who he was texting, sliding into his room as he drifted off to sleep. He'd been looking right at me as the bullet bounced off me and struck his skull. He's going to recover from that, by the way. His vitals are good.
哇。我真的低估了这个家伙。我像看旋转木马幻灯片一样翻阅他的近期往事。我盯着乌马尔在马里的整个期间，他一直在盯着我，或者尝试盯着我。他确实在我最粗心的时候瞥见了我几次，他在我绕到他身后看他在给谁发短信，在我溜进他房间时他正陷入沉睡时。当子弹从我身上弹开打中他的头骨时，他正正地看着我。顺便说一句，他会康复的。他的生命体征很好。
I find myself thinking, maybe I don't have to do what I came here to do after all. It's not like he actually saw my face. So what if he wakes up and tells a few more people he saw a ghost? What's the harm in that? The thought surprises me. I'm used to cleaning up after myself. But I'm also relieved. I back away from the hospital bed, thinking if I leave now, I'll still have a pretty good head start on whatever spooks are chasing me down.
我发现自己在想，也许我不需要做我来这里做的事了。毕竟他并没有真的看到我的脸。那又怎样？如果他醒过来，告诉更多人他看到了鬼魂？那又有什么害处呢？这个想法让我自己都感到惊讶。我习惯了清理自己的后事。但我也感到释然。我后退离开医院病床，想如果我现在离开，我在任何追捕我的鬼魂面前都还能有相当大的领先优势。
That's when it occurs to me. I can't just leave him here. The people who are coming after me have way more to lose than I do. If they're ready to kill me for stealing the suit, they'll take Oumar out just for knowing about it. I'm still holding his hand. I squeeze his fingers, scan his dark features, and then I realized, I can't let that happen. I have to protect him.
就在这时，我意识到了一件事。我不能就这样把他留在这里。那些来追我的人比我损失的东西要多得多。如果他们为了夺回套装而准备杀我，他们也会仅仅因为乌马尔知道这件事而把他干掉。我仍然握着他的手。我紧紧抓着他的手指，看着他黑色的五官，然后我意识到，我不能让那种事发生。我必须保护他。
The thought really freaks me out. It seems to come from somewhere deeper inside me than me, pulled up to the surface by-- by-- oh, shit. It's the suit. I know it. First, it has me reading minds, and now I'm supposed to care about this guy. Not convenient. Not cool. I could die right here today fighting for some African dude I don't even know, all because of a double extra strength dose of melanin.
这个想法真的把我吓坏了。它似乎来自我内心深处，被——被——噢，见鬼。是这套衣服。我知道是它。首先，它让我读心，现在我又必须关心这个家伙。太不方便了。太不酷了。我可能今天就要死在这里，为某个我不认识的非洲人而战，全是因为这超强剂量的黑色素。
I get a text from Gina that reads simply, "as you were." I know she means they're coming, and I should run. I don't. I move to stand between Oumar's bed and the door. I've got no weapon, and my hand-to-hand combat training is rusty as all hell. Pray the ancestors can help me with that. I take off my earrings.
我收到吉娜的一条短信，内容仅仅是：“保持原样。”我知道她是说他们来了，我该跑了。我没跑。我走到乌马尔的床和门之间。我没有武器，我的肉搏训练已经生锈透了。祈求祖先能在这一点上帮我吧。我摘下耳环。
Susan K. Watson reading a short story by Neil Drumming. Susan is in the TV show This is Us, which has a new season, and she's in the Mr. Rogers film with Tom Hanks. It's coming out soon.
苏珊·K·沃森朗读尼尔·德拉明的短篇故事。苏珊在电视节目《我们这一天》里，该剧有新一季，她还在汤姆·汉克斯的《邻里美好的一天》电影里演出。电影很快就要上映了。
[MUSIC - OINGO BOINGO, "WEIRD SCIENCE"]
[音乐 - OINGO BOINGO，“怪诞科学”]
Our program was produced today by Neil Drumming. The people who put our show together include Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由尼尔·德拉明制作。组成我们节目组的人包括伊曼纽尔·贝里、苏珊·伯顿、肖恩·科尔、杰西卡·卢森霍普、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。我们的执行主编是戴安·吴。我们的执行编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks today to Carrie Morgan, Alvin Melathe, Peter Warren and AVN, Zoe Ligon, Wendy Zukerman, Kaitlyn Sawrey, and Lois Drabkin. Original music for our science fiction story in the third act was composed by Blue Dot Sessions, Ricardo Gutierrez, and Andrae Taylor.
今天特别感谢嘉莉·摩根、阿尔文·梅拉特、彼得·沃伦和 AVN、佐伊·利贡、温迪·祖克曼、凯特琳·索里和洛伊丝·德拉布金。第三幕中科幻故事的原创音乐由 Blue Dot Sessions、里卡多·古铁雷斯和安德烈·泰勒创作。
Our website thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 680 episodes for absolutely free. There's also videos and tons of other stuff there. Go get our app, which has all that stuff and also lets you download as many episodes as you want. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体收听我们超过 680 集的存档。还有视频和大量其他内容。去下载我们的应用程序，它拥有所有这些内容，还可以让你下载任意数量的剧集。再次提醒，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共无线电交换机构（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he was complaining this week about how boring weddings seem to him these days. And he got all-- I don't know-- he got all nostalgic about how they were so much more fun back in the '70s.
一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他这周还在抱怨现在的婚礼对他来说显得多么无聊。然后他变得——我不知道——他变得非常怀旧，谈论 70 年代的时候婚礼是多么有趣。
And they would have, you know, tables for porn stars to sit and sign autographs.
那时他们会有，你知道，桌子让色情明星坐下来签名。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - OINGO BOINGO, "WEIRD SCIENCE"]
[音乐 - OINGO BOINGO，“怪诞科学”]